>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> An introduction to the
IQ Five Battery Analyzer.
>> KEVIN WATSON: Hi.
I'm Kevin Watson and I'm the
equipment repair officer here
at NLS in Washington, DC.
This video is an introduction to
using the iQ5 Battery Analyzer.
NLS provides the IQ Five Battery
Analyzer to the repair network
for testing and analyzing
Talking Book Machine Batteries.
All batteries, whether from a
machine returned from a patron
or from new stock, should
be tested before re-using.
Before we start analyzing batteries,
I want to show you how to set
up the IQ5 so that
it is ready to use.
To set up your iQ5 Battery Analyzer,
you will need a flat blade
screwdriver and 6 DTB Adapters.
The DTB adapters are
available from NLS.
You can order them using the WOW
system, under stock number ITECH C.
If you are going to be
analyzing C-1 batteries,
you can order the C-1 adapters
from the WOW system too,
stock number iTech B. Remove
your analyzer from the box.
Note that the iQ5 is
cooled by a fan in the back
so be sure you leave enough
room behind it to circulate air.
Your iQ5 comes equipped with a
power button, a printer port,
six adapter slots,
and a display screen
and three buttons for each slot.
>> Set Up
>> KEVIN WATSON: To set up your iQ5,
you will need to remove the slot
covers and install the adapters
for each slot you plan to use.
You should not plug the unit in
until all adapters are installed.
Remove the cover on the first
slot using the screwdriver.
Be sure to keep all covers you
remove nearby because you will have
to put them back on
each slot not in use.
Never install or uninstall adapters
while the unit is plugged in.
Note that the connection of the far
left is positioned a bit different
from the others.
You should always connect
the adapters beginning
from the far right before
connecting the others.
Only remove the covers of slots
you plan to attach an adapter to.
Connect the adapter to
the slot connection.
Repeat this effort for each
slot you plan to use until all
of the covers are removed
and adapters connected.
Make sure the power button is
OFF, then plug in your iQ5.
Turn the power ON.
Note that you do not need to turn
your iQ5 off unless you are going
to install or uninstall an adapter.
Now that all of your adapters are
attached and your iQ5 is plugged in
and powered up, we are ready
to begin testing batteries.
To demonstrate the iQ5 I'm going
to make use of several boxes.
This is just one way you
can organize your battery
testing operation.
Here I have four boxes.
I've labeled them: Pass,
Test, Fail, and Condition.
When a player is returned
from a patron,
you should remove the battery
and place it in the Test box.
You should take a known-good battery
and install it in the player.
As you test your batteries using
the iQ5, you should pull one
from the Test box and then
put it in the Pass, Fail,
or Condition box depending
on the results of the test.
The iQ5 has five modes:
Charge, Discharge,
Cycle Test, Analyze, Condition.
Charge. Charges a battery
and sets it to trickle,
which is a holding charge.
Discharge.
Discharges a battery to
test, charges the battery,
and then sets it to trickle.
Analyze. Charges, discharges
to test, recharges,
and then sets the battery
to trickle.
Condition.
Charges and discharges to
test a battery three times
and then sets it to trickle.
Cycle Test.
Charges and discharges to test.
This loop has to be manually
stopped by removing the battery.
>> Charging Mode, Discharging
Mode, and Cycle Test Mode.
>> KEVIN WATSON: Generally speaking,
repair staff will not be using
the Charging, Discharging,
or Cycle Test modes on the iQ5.
When you attach a battery to the
iQ5, it will automatically go
into Charging mode unless
you select another option.
Using the iQ5 for charging
batteries is not recommended.
A digital talking book player will
charge a battery in half the time.
If you only need to charge a
battery, use a player instead
to keep the slots on
your iQ5 available
for testing or conditioning.
Discharging and Cycle test modes
are advanced functions of the iQ5
that we will not be
covering in this video.
>> Analyze Mode - Used Batteries
>> KEVIN WATSON: Analyze mode will
be the most used mode on your iQ5.
To analyze a battery that
has been out in the field,
connect it to the adapter,
and push the Analyze button.
In my demonstration, I'm going to
take 6 batteries from my Test box,
attach them to the iQ5 adapters,
and push the Analyze
button on each display.
The iQ5 will take several
hours to analyze a battery,
so you can leave and come back.
When you return to your iQ5, check
the display panel for the results.
The lowest acceptable level for
battery analysis is 650 mAh,
which is equivalent to
16 hours of playtime
in a digital talking book player.
If you get a reading of 650 mAh
or higher, remove that battery
from the iQ5 and place it
in the box marked Pass.
If you get a reading of 649 mAh
or below, remove that battery
from the iQ5 and place it
in the box marked Fail.
Remember, this is for batteries
that have been out in the field.
>> Analyze Mode - Unused Batteries
>> KEVIN WATSON: Now
we are going to talk
about analyzing unused batteries.
To keep your operation
as efficient as possible,
you should analyze a sample from
every box of unused batteries.
Remove six unused batteries
from the box.
Connect each of them
to a slot on the iQ5.
Push the Analyze button
on each display.
Leave the iQ5 to do the
analyzing and come back later.
When you return, read the
results on each display.
For practical purposes, we
should set the acceptable limit
for unused batteries at
1000 mAh, which translates
to 24 hours of playtime on the DTBM.
Remove batteries that return a
reading of 1000 mAh or better
from the iQ5 and place them
in the box marked Pass.
If any of the batteries in the test
sample return a reading of less
than 1000 mAhs, you should
remove them and place them
in the box labeled Condition.
It's a good idea to analyze the
entire box of unused batteries
if any in your sample yield
results lower than 1000 mAh to weed
out any defective batteries.
>> Conditioning Mode
>> KEVIN WATSON: Conditioning unused
batteries will either bring them
up to acceptable levels or it
will detect if they are defective.
To condition batteries,
attach them to the slots
and press the Condition
button on each display.
Conditioning mode goes through
three charge and discharge cycles.
It may take a while to
run through the cycles.
So, once you press
the condition button,
you can leave and come back later.
When you return, read the
results on each display.
Again we are looking
for 1000 mAh or better.
Batteries that show 1000
mAh or better on the display
when the conditioning cycle
is complete, can be removed
and placed in the box labeled Pass.
When the conditioning cycle is
complete, you should run batteries
that read less than 1000 mAhs
through a second condition cycle
by pressing the condition button.
Again, this will take some time,
so come back and check on it later.
After a second conditioning cycle,
if your batteries are still reading
under 1000 mAh, it's safe
to say they are defective.
They should be removed
from the iQ5 and placed
in the Fail box for proper disposal.
This concludes the introduction
to the iQ5 Battery Analyzer.
Remember that we are a service
oriented operation and it's
up to you to make sure that
DTBM batteries are functioning
at an acceptable level when the
players are delivered to patrons.
If you have problems or questions
about using the iQ5 Battery
Analyzer, please contact me,
Kevin Watson at 202-707-9298
or by email at kwat@loc.gov.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc dot gov.